[Applause]
so i'm just happy that i
released a project i saw my billboard on
sunset across the street from the
chateau
which is i saw that yeah yeah because uh
my third album is going to be recorded
in the chateau
okay yeah so this is exclusive stuff
that i'm telling you actually i've never
told anyone
um third album was recorded on in the
chateau
because of uh john belushi where
that's where he passed yeah and he's a
big big influence
and big inspiration because he was the
first albanian
male in hollywood wow i didn't know that
i didn't even know he was he was
albanian
yeah i have him tattered on me as well
and you know have you met his brother
yes i've actually i'm from jim um jim
jim had a run too man that's you know
i've had lunch with him i'm friends with
his kids and stuff
like we talk on instagram so you and the
belushi's got some
some uh some some genuine relationships
yeah i've
met them met his brother couple times
but as far as like john like john
john just probably a lot of inspiration
as a kid being like yo somebody from
where i'm from yeah has made it into
hollywood it's never happened i mean
look at the albanian artists
you know uh i didn't even know duleep it
was albanian but then again
it doesn't matter that's look what
you're saying i i don't listen to
dualipa but hold on though
look what you're saying did you know
rita ora was
i did not exactly look what you're
saying
did you yeah well ended there
so there's like i just think it's dope
that you rep that [ __ ] like you know
what i'm saying i think it's important
make sure make sure that you send me
that clip exactly
how what just happened right now send it
to me because i want to post it on my
social media
because see my country right now is not
on the map
on apple apple's not putting my country
on a map kosovo
and you got all these girl artists right
now
saying complaining that they should put
it on the map
how are you expecting anyone to put
anything on a map if you never put it on
a map
if you don't talk about it if you hide
where you're from
and you're hiding because you want to be
cool i've been repping where i'm from
since i came in this business
nothing's changed i have that [ __ ]
tattered i have kosovo on my belly i
have it on my hand you have to see i
can't hide it
you understand they don't rep it and now
they don't have us on the map
and it's because you never wrapped it
and i'm not saying dooley because
duolippa's been wrapping it and she's
slowly she's from london as well but
like a lot of the other girls they don't
rep that [ __ ]
so i i'm i'm a little so as a kid
obviously i remember just on the news
the kosovo
conflict that was going on when clinton
was president yeah um
i'm not educated so you could educate me
albania kosovo is is coast like like
kind of
being kosovo is is we're basically
brother and sister you know what i'm
saying
same thing yes i'm just trying to you
know it's the same thing basically
but kosovo it's his own country but
serbia and kosovo
have gone into it because of land and
and we got our independence finally but
they still
are not acknowledging us as a country on
on the google maps and putting us
they're putting us as a number
wow you understand that's a problem
because we did
get our independence we are a country a
kosovo is our country
the other thing that pisses me off is
the fact that you know
we shared the flag with albania we
shared the same flag and now we have our
blue flag which is like blue and yellow
flag
and i don't really respect that because
i i because
my people died for that flag and now
you've given us independence but a new
flag it's like
it's not it's like you know what i mean
it's like putting a band-aid over
a cut you know i'm saying but you know i
want us to be respected as a country and
i want us to be put on the map
nothing hurts me more in my heart it's
like every time i land in kosovo i feel
like i'm getting stabbed in the throat
every time my iphone says welcome to
serbia
wow because my my i have families that
died they died you know what i'm saying
sorry about that no it's all good man i
mean i do feel like i i have families
that died
for this country to be acknowledged i
have families
family members and my people died i've
my people have been raped my people have
been slaughtered
and they've been through a lot for this
country
and now you're not putting us on a map
what type of [ __ ] is that you know
what i mean we've been through it all
and we deserve
to be respected and acknowledged as a
country i think it's important to
educate people on that because
you know we just had somebody my boy
armen from armenia was
kind of educating me on uh you know how
a lot of people don't
acknowledge the armenian genocide yeah
and a lot of people just don't know
you know and i think that with the
kosovo thing like for me i just kind of
have like i guess a generic
remembrance of being a kid and seeing
the news seeing that there was a
conflict there but i don't necessarily
know
i i don't really know what happened
outside of their you know just seeing
clinton
i think what did u.s aid kosovo
yeah yeah um yeah man i'm
we're going to talk about that when the
camera is okay okay fair enough yeah
we'll talk about that i mean i just
think you know at the end of the day
like
no no no i get now what you said
i just don't want to get too deep into
it because we'll be in the rabbit hole
but what i'm saying to you is
you know every day i fight for my music
but at the same time i don't
want to forget my roots and where i'm
from you know
even though my my people at times could
be super toxic
on me because that one day i don't rep
or say i'm from kosovo they just come
down on me so much any mistake i make
they come down on me and
it's because you know sometimes your
people are harder on you than
than everyone else everyone else you
know i'm saying so
um but i've been repping
and you you're proof of that saying yo i
always knew you were all being
because i've been saying it since the
beginning of my career you know
and um
yeah i'm changing i'm changing that and
i just think you know what man
i love my country because they keep me
alive you know once america is over with
gashy and they move on to the next act
my country's gonna keep me alive forever
and that's what keeps drake popping
because canada loves him
and that's what keeps rihanna popping
because she her country loves her
that's what keeps kendrick popping
because that lady loves him right you
know what i'm saying
once you have your hometown you could
get the whole world and you will always
be relevant you always make money
because
people know you have roots to someplace
when you come and you don't have love in
your own country and you think you get
pop in a different city you'll get pop
in
five [ __ ] minutes and be out and then
you're done you're done i love my people
i rep for my people you know i'm saying
these pop artists
this is why i rep i love jim belushi and
this is why my third album is so about
him
it's about me going fully hollywood it's
about me going fully pop
because he's the only male albanian to
ever be allowed in hollywood
do you know how difficult it is to be
accepted in hollywood you don't
understand especially in the 80s
except yeah right i'm about to be
accepted in hollywood
for the first time with this 1984 album
and in my third one i'm from
i'm fully gonna be hollywood
fully be celebrity right you know you
know what i'm saying
so you said like the target walmart
reference exactly that might be the last
yeah this might be the last thing so
it's a big deal when you have eight
girls right now
on the billboard charts that are
albanian that are
killing it and i'm the only
male albanian to ever do it in america
ever they will ever
you don't know when next time you'll see
me
i'm a total different beast you will
never
you will never this might be the last
time you
ever see anything like this in your
entire life that's how crazy it is for
my country
super super super super solid
super duper
solid people you can't even wear a pink
shirt
around someone super
aggressive manly
man to see me do pop music and dance the
way i do
to be acknowledging ellen john and be
saying
dressing up with my pants the way they
are and doing this like
such a culture shock what is this kid
doing
why is he talking to the kids from my
country like it's okay it's a right to
accept
everyone for who they are it's a right
to do this it's a right to
not being a gangster throwing up gang
signs shooting people i'm on new york
times not because i caught bodies
because of my music
it's a total different thing that my
country's never seen before
the kids are looking at me like what the
hell i don't have to kill someone to be
famous
like i'm totally going in a different
direction and a lot of people are trying
to close doors on me
that are in the hollywood but they can't
because i'm fully
in now i'm officially in now you can't
stop it anymore
and i earned my way in i wrote every
single song with my bare hands you can't
stop it
i made it this is why it's a big deal
for my country this is why it's a big
deal for a male
like me to be in there because i'm
teaching all the kids
rather they're gay rather they're
they're into like
pop music rather they're actually into
the color pink and are
probably straight that maybe they're
into the things that they're not
supposed to be into
i'm i'm trying to teach them that
they're it's okay it's okay to like
it's okay to be yourself to be yourself
it's okay to like the things you like
it's okay
and that is what i'm doing and i think
it's the biggest moment for my country